listen Rachel I have heard of all types
of different days out there okay I've
heard that there's a national taco day
even the national pizza day oh there's a
national pizza day is that national
sibling day was earlier this month or
late April okay isn't theirs but did you
may or may not be a margarita day
I'm just saying okay you wouldn't know
about that but listen did you know that
there's a national life insurance day
yeah now listen it's one of those things
that that people don't think about but
Dave recently posted a compelling video
on his Facebook and Instagram and I dare
you to watch it and not cry as you think
about this it's so important for us to
make sure that we have protection for
ourselves and our families the here's
the story of the video Sondra is a young
lady who had 80,000 in student loan debt
after listening to this show she and her
husband started work in the plan Rachel
- paid off debt they got insurance life
insurance that we recommend they soon
found out they were pregnant but shortly
after their new baby was born the
husbands suddenly died and as you can
imagine they your life went from perfect
to absolutely just devastate it I can't
even imagine their feeling but in the
middle of grieving the last thing you
want to have to deal with this financial
stress figuring out how you're gonna pay
for bills how are you gonna take care of
your family and do what's necessary but
here's the thing because they got
disciplined they got themselves out of
debt and they actually heard the advice
and took the step they were able to put
themselves in a position to take care of
their family family and it's so very
important and you know everyone always
thinks Rachel that's not gonna happen to
them you know they really do and so it's
so important for you to take care of
your family you know show them you love
them and so I want to encourage you to
go get an insurance checkup go to Dave
Ramsey comm slash checkup take our five
minute coverage checkup and you can
figure out what you need if you need to
add if you need to adjust or tweak it's
right there love your family enough to
take that step again go to Dave Ramsey
comm slash checkup
life insurance is just that important
America